hi I'm Timmy the trashcan and I love
trash
popcorn box candy wrappers
they all taste so good instead of
throwing your trash on the floor won't
you please give it to me
thank you for considering your fellow
patrons welcome to the Tim Dylan show
everybody it is Tuesday October 1st the
beginning of silver October for Bert re
Tom Rogan I'm leaving in a few hours
from this porch to go and get on a tour
bus will fly first and they got on a
tour bus with Bert Kreischer and then
I'm opening for him on the first leg the
first couple of dates the first week of
his body shots
world tour very excited for that
Bert sober I'm doing Kido so it's gonna
be a lot of fun a real wild time but it
should be good man I'm really psyched
and pumped to see people and we just got
back from Logan Paul's house we just did
impulsive the podcast a lot of fun
there's a helicopter going over we're
gonna give that a minute Logan Paul man
beautiful home Ben said it but it was
like he lives like the kid in blank
check yeah like there's toys everywhere
and cars everywhere and Friends
everywhere it's a good life really is
he's actually a nice guy he's training
for the fight he's to him with ksi and
we had a great podcast there was a lot
of fun you know and I explained in the
previous episode with Ray the futility
of being angry at the youtubers that's
over you can be angry at them you can be
angry at anybody does it matter you know
that whole you know response to Theo guy
when you had Logan on and response that
I got
why kill polio how about no there was a
lot of people that were like hey how
about know you're talking to that guy
and a lot of people just hate the kid
because they don't feel like he deserves
to be famous
hey you get famous I mean I don't know
what to tell you this whole idea of
deserve is a word that a child would use
it's it's a child that throws a tantrum
I wanted it should be mine and that his
get over it deserve he works hard Fame
is not a thing that you you discuss in
those terms um
you could discuss respect in that way
you could say this person deserves to be
respected or they don't or their art or
their work deserves to be respected or
it doesn't you can have conversations
using that framing when you're talking
about respect when you're talking about
legacy when you're talking about
influence but when you're talking about
something as fickle and as vacuous as
Fame especially right now you'll you'll
find yourself chasing your own tail this
person this this person deserves Fame
these people are famous for no reason
well the reason is it people watch and
listen to what they do that's why
they're famous and I'm not even trying
to be a contrarian here I'm saying that
is the reason so your quarrel is really
and I had to realize this folks I was
kind of one of these people and this is
why people acquire blood pooling all the
time I'm not black Atilla I realized my
quarrel
is not as much with the politicians it's
not as much with the entertainers it's
with the people it's with my fellow
citizens
that's the quarrel that's why people
have guns I figured it out it's not to
fight the government is to shoot their
neighbor in the face it's so that the
people in this country can defend each
other from each other that's why people
are armed to the teeth and they all have
Arsenal's not do they think they're
gonna take on the Green Berets because
they're gonna take on you know when red
it goes live when Facebook when we win
when it's Facebook live in the streets
that's what a cut Mike were your quarrel
is with the people it's not with it's
not with the bold-faced names it really
isn't
you know I talked to so many comedians
so many people in the arts or an
entertainment and they're like can you
believe that this is getting the
attention it's getting whatever it
happens to be and it's like hey man talk
to the people now there's a lot of
things in entertainment where they are
propped up by writers and reviewers and
journalists and media and the people
want nothing to do with it
but in the case of Logan and these
YouTube guys they have the numbers they
have legions of fans so I don't know
what to tell you get a life literally
get a life find somebody to love figure
something out get a job that fulfills
you get a hobby
the great Rick Campos used to talk about
hobbies but sending me a message saying
I shouldn't go on the podcast when the
guy is a perfectly nice guy do you know
how many podcasts of people I do I hate
do you know in the business how many
times I have to talk to people I hate
them is guys
he's a sweet kid now I I don't know I
mean there's things we've all done
things and said things that we don't
want on our epitaph in a funeral we
don't like in a cemetery we don't want
it on our hair on her headstone
everybody has done that [ __ ] get over
it this rage you know when I talk about
Dozier Kat I don't begrudge her her fame
of course juicy is a song I of course
she's famous
it would make so much less sense if she
wasn't famous that song on YouTube mu
where she goes [ __ ] I'm a cow [ __ ] I'm
a cow I'm not a cat
I don't say meow of course that has 54
million views go outside talk to someone
anyone you'll get it watch a few minutes
of the news look at our political
leaders look at the fact that no one
wants to go into politics anymore
because they feel like they can really
change the world more intact or working
and you know that fake charity circuit
that [ __ ] philanthropy they all do
well they all pretty you know they
donate money for tax reasons but they
don't want to work in politics because
politics is just very dirty so many and
a lot of people talk is is the recipient
of a lot of talent that would have gone
into politics or would have gone into
finance they go into tact because they
think they think that their altruism has
a better place intact now we know what
altruism attack is it's being super woke
for the corporate state it's it's giving
are giving yourself over to the idea
that surveillance not a problem
not an issue
d platforming people not a problem as
long as you are on the ideological
spectrum of the people that work in
those companies and I know some of those
people I talked to them but none of
those people are revolutionaries but
they do believe that they're making the
world a better place they believe that's
what they're doing and if you go to them
with facts or statistics or a
counter-argument based in one of those
two things they tend not to receive that
well
they don't receive that criticism well
because they believe that they are
literally changing the world and that
they are the guardians of our democratic
process and they are the guardians of
free speech and they will decide who
should have it and when it should be had
but it was a fun podcast check that out
that's probably out already this is
gonna come out you know Saturday night
Sunday I talked about this article on
the patreon episode I want everybody to
read this article because it's a [ __ ]
killer article and to their credit the
New York Times published it it's called
how to hide four hundred million dollars
okay was written by Nicolas confess or a
published on November 30th 2016 how to
hide four hundred million dollars it is
so good I'll give you a little preview
and then I want you to go read it we're
not talking about it really today this
is just assignments this is homework I
give you homework and if your members of
the patreon you already got this when a
wealthy businessman set out to divorce
his wife their fortune vanished the
quest to find it would reveal the depths
of an offshore financial system bigger
than the US economy and what's great
about the articles you read it you start
understanding that Epstein was not only
the island wasn't only the sexual
blackmail but it was this huge operation
to launder money to wash dirty money
that came from a lot of different places
came from a lot of private
you know major players in the financial
world and it also came from corporations
and Epstein was a guy who was very
skilled at doing that and that's from on
the record and off the record
conversations I've had with a lot of
people that believe that the full scope
of what he was involved in actually is
heinous and as shocking as the human
trafficking was and the allegations
about that which were all true there is
something even larger in scope when you
talk about the financial system that
exists only for the wealthiest most
powerful people in the world and the way
that they're able to hide money offshore
overseas very fascinating article and
we're gonna try to get some people on
the show to talk about that is very very
interesting folks better help slash Tim
Dylan we've discussed better help before
and I've been quite clear about an open
and honest with the audience about you
know some of the controversies that
better help was mired in and my decision
to continue to let them advertise on the
program because I do feel like there are
people out there in the world with a
sexual fetish who want to masturbate on
the phone with a stranger and that this
service for a small monthly fee is the
way to do that safely and you're
probably not going to lose your job so
that is a great use of the service now
of course better help is intended for
people that want counseling from
licensed counselors and that is also a
feature that they offer that is not the
future that I have chosen to focus on I
think we've kind of done our own thing
here with the better help ABS this will
kind of be our final one but I mean
listen this is better than nothing if
you are out there and you're desperate
you need to talk to somebody better help
is really the way to do it I mean a lot
of people cannot afford they don't have
the health insurance and cannot afford
a counselor a lot of them don't want to
leave their house they anxiety they
don't want to sit in front of somebody
and they want an online counseling
session anytime you can schedule it if
you don't like your counselor you can
leave but if you do like your counselor
and you know what I'm in this is
probably a great way to masturbate on
the phone while someone is talking to
you and not lose your job or get
arrested better help / Tim Dale I'm
trying to book I'm trying to book some
dates in London over the holidays
because I want to be a victim of
terrorism in the UK I've sat down with
my agent always said it would be really
good it would kind of get you know I
don't know that I'm a sympathetic figure
but I feel like if I'm plowed down in a
open Street market in Britain by
somebody not not hurt but just kind of
knocked over knocked off my axis I think
it might make me look a little better
but now I'm seriously thinking about
going over there doing some shows and
then maybe shooting a special that I
might distribute myself over at The
Stand comedy club in Glasgow which was
one of my favorite rooms in the world
and I love going over there and I
haven't really been on a V on a vacation
in a long time like I haven't been on a
vacation and the vacations I went on
when I was a kid we're okay
they were I mean my parents took me to
one place called the enchanted forest
which is I think up by Canada by the
border I don't know what the [ __ ] they
were doing they're trying to probably
try to sell me to pedophiles who then
once they saw me reneged and they were
like okay I guess we'll have to take him
to the theme park now and then I went to
Disney World twice we've talked about
that at nauseam I went to a castle in
Scotland with my dad we talked about
that we did not take a lot of vacations
as a family it was not a thing that we
did and I don't take a lot of them now
so I don't have a lot of money
and you know so I would like to get over
there to the UK to see if so what's it
about what's going on over there
you got Bragg's head you got Boris
Johnson what's the deal let me sink my
teeth into that socio-political climate
go ahead and criticize their food you
know get a British twink you know one of
them is really goth and pale you know
maybe one of the Harry Potter kids who's
grown up is now on drugs spent most of
their money
me and Ben we're watching today we're
watching like you remember if you grew
up you remember TGIF and yet Family
Matters step by step hang Boy Meets
World and hangin with mr. Cooper those
were like the shows you would watch as a
kid Friday night TGIF thank God it's
Friday and I don't know if they even
have TGIF on ABC anymore they probably
don't those were like the shows for kids
on Friday night it was a fun yeah that
ended in 2003 it ended in 2003 then all
the kids started watching 24 they
started watching jack bow or torture
terrorists there's a ticking time bomb
we need to get information from this
terrorist before a nuclear weapon goes
off Jack Bauer will do it nothing I love
that the very few pop culture phenomenon
did more to legitimize torture than 2424
was cited as a reason that torture
worked people freaked people forgot that
it was a show it was a show and people
big whoa you don't understand did you
see 24 and you'd go that's a show yeah
but that's the way it happens no yeah no
usually when you have a ticking time
bomb scenario it's too late okay dum-dum
that's too late it's not not working
when the bomb is already in place and
it's literally ticking that's movie [ __ ]
that doesn't work but I love that that
was a pop culture phenomenon 24 will you
look back at these shows it's gonna be
it's gonna be amazing to look back at
all of the and they were not even good
like all of these garbage things that
made us think that the Iraq war was like
a good idea all these movies that made
us think that these things were cool
what about flight 93 that was a great
dad how did 9/11 happen watch flight 93
shut up
well you just watch it what let's reset
let's roll and then he killed the
terrorists on the plane and then he took
that plane and he captured bin Laden we
won't even know we'll just we won't even
know what the real because our our minds
will be melted by drugs and food and
adderall and Taco Bell by the time our
kids come to ask us try to explain any
event to your children
just it's impossible I mean can you
imagine 15 years if kids are trying to
explain to them like the Iraq war you're
like ah well uh nineteen hijackers
hijacked a plane nineteen hijackers
hijack one no no no a lot of planes how
many planes I don't know I don't know
and then they drove them in they flew
them into buildings of the Pentagon and
and then we we went to war with
Afghanistan and Iraq why be well because
Saddam Hussein had weapons of mass
destruction we thought but he didn't and
then we went to war there how long were
we awarded twelve twenty years twenty
years in Afghanistan in Iraq and then
what happened then we elected Donald
Trump
how did Trump get elected well he was
funny he was entertaining and we got to
a point in our country where every
politician just lied to our faces very
professionally and we wanted to elect
somebody who would ruin the country we
knew that was gonna happen
we wanted to elect a guy where there was
a very good chance he would burn
everything down and that's why we
elected him because we thought there was
a good chance that he could either turn
around like I remember one guy who say
to me goes you know what I think
Long Island guy Long Island people never
need to be asked their opinions they
always just cuz you know what I think I
think Trump's gotta be the best
president ever I was like okay and then
if you ask you there's Krita bubbling
out ask him a follow-up question they go
like this you go why do you think that
they go watch
that's the Long Island follow up they go
watch yo dude that that business gonna
fail why do you say that watch it's a
great way to not have reasoning for
whatever you're saying it's huge in Long
Island I don't know where you people
grew up very big in Long Island my dad
would say it all the time because he
used to say things have made no sense
and then he'd be like just watch just
watch and then you'd watch and it
wouldn't happen and then of course you
wouldn't bring it up to them again it
was just they won the moment in their
own head by saying watch six months
later of course that didn't happen you
know it's just okay how'd that work out
for you how's that working out for you
shut up then they'd have a new thing
they'd always be onto a new thing mm-hmm
Monday calm Monday calm folks we've
talked about this many of you are
looking to maximize the efficiency of
your business that is what you're
looking to do you don't know how to do
it it eludes you and what Monday com
helps you do is it as a software tool
that helps you Oregon
everything going on in your business
it's intuitive flexible easy to stay
organized and find files creates
accountability so nobody is gonna be
like why did you miss the email why
weren't you at the meeting why didn't
you dial into the conference call why
are you screwing up my life Doreen you
know this is a much easier way to avoid
all of that messy drama some people love
drama they like gossiping and you know
they like backbiting and they like to
blame each other that they live for that
it's something that they enjoy gives
their meaningless lives some level of
excitement take it away from them take
that coffee clutch that that that gossip
away from them and make these people
work make them find truly interesting
things to sink their teeth into to not
give them the gift of office drama
because you know they love it okay
Monday comm / Tim all lowercase Monday
comm / Tim all lowercase letters you
will get a free 14-day trial there's no
commitment you can check out Monday com
see for yourself how helpful their
software is if you do not like the
software you do not have to buy it
it is a 14-day free trial but I
guarantee you after this is gonna work
so well you're probably gonna fire most
of your employees and then they can
figure out what to do with the rest of
their lives and how to feed their kids
because you are organized streamlined
and you don't need them so you kick them
right into the street and you keep going
doing what you need to do to make your
business a great efficient machine
that's why I recommend Monday comm you
get in that 14-day free trial and make
sure you use that exact link if you're
using my link there will be additional
savings even after the free trial if you
choose to sign up so Monday comm / Tim
14-day free
trial that my friends is the move that's
what you need to do one of the glimpses
into insanity that I got and I got a lot
of them and I've probably given many
people some of them but one of the
glimpses of insanity I got that I take
with me and I found to have a lot of
value comedic ly and otherwise was a man
named Howard
we called him Howie Howie used to work
in mortgages with me and how he was a
small man he was short diminutive in
stature but he was very loud and he
talked with his hands like this and he
was what he was who you would cast in a
movie like boiler room he was who he
would cast in a movie like the Big Short
he was exactly the person that you
imagined would occupy that type of space
he drove a BMW truck he lived in a condo
in a not a great part of Long Island it
was by the water and he made no money at
the office because he was a horrible
salesman he made the majority of his
money selling cocaine and the cocaine
was not good it was very bad cocaine it
was it was so bad you would do it and go
is this cocaine that's how bad his
cocaine was but he he believed in his
head that he was the greatest salesman
of all time and the only other job he
had before he worked at our company was
he worked at a lack of all Street that
was famously basically it was a currency
trading firm that was essentially just
the bank accounts of the Russian mob and
it was you know and it was legit legit
in terms of that there was a lot of
people making a lot of money but it was
also a complete and total fraud he comes
out of that company he landed in Long
Island with me I thought this guy was
very funny because he was insane I
always loved people that did it that the
facts
were irrelevant we're completely
irrelevant like he didn't sell any
mortgages and he didn't make any money
from our company but yet he would still
walk around the office as if he was the
CFO like he was a CEO like the guy
didn't care that he was it and he would
say that he wasn't making money because
the company sucked like everybody else
was making money people were making
30,000 a month I wasn't making that but
there were people making a lot of money
and how I was like a young guy was at 22
or 21 and and maybe even younger and
Hallie was just this character that
liked me immediately because I I spoke
well and I was good on the phone you
could put me on the phone with a client
but I would listen to Howie when the
bosses would tell me to go don't say
anything how he says he's a bad salesman
and we probably shouldn't even have him
here because he doesn't care but it was
the facts were relevant to him they
didn't matter because he had a condo and
he had a Beemer and people were like I
think his parents paid for it
and people I think he sells coke to make
that money and people that gave the
cokes horrible who's buying that well a
good point
so nobody knew how he had any of this
money but he didn't even have that much
money but he had enough his friends had
money people like to keep him around
because he was crazy I mean he would the
the the company we worked for was called
Franklin first and he would call people
up on the phone and say things that were
so unbelievably untrue provably untrue
baseless that people would be like I
mean he called you would call up people
and you'd go hi this is how he from
Franklin first you know Ben Franklin
they'd go what people did even know
people would be like the Ben Franklin
start the bank he'd go he was involved I
mean people he said once he's like I'm
standing in the stock exchange right now
in an office overlooking the stock if no
nobody even knew those possible welllook
are there even offices on the second
floor of the but he was calling people
like the middle of the country who had
like like like modular homes like huge
I remember once he was trying to do a
deal of this woman who had a modular
home which is essentially a double-wide
on a foundation
he had like up the file and it's like he
goes he won't you the secretary's office
she goes what the [ __ ] is the problem
that's waste that's the way he's the dog
to our secretary Kelly who's just a
drunk smoke Barbie Reds Barbara arrives
and she was like she goes lower your
voice who the [ __ ] are you talking to
like that he goes what the [ __ ] is a
problem he goes I can't close the deal
of this goddamn place and Kelly goes the
woman who told you it's a modular she
goes it's actually a double-wide so we
can't do a double-wide and she throw the
deal back it up
so then how we get on the phone with the
woman I need to go hey
apparently it's a double-wide is this
true woman goes no it's a modular and
then how we would like cover the phone
and scream at the secretary god it's a
[ __ ] and by the way total Commission
on this movie right maybe $1,200 right
maybe $20 but he's screaming he's
screaming got them he's gotta cover the
[ __ ] yes it's a [ __ ] modular I told
you that and then and then he get back
on the fourth a woman in the woman's
like you know I'm looking at some of the
papers and I don't have the certified
modular paper and then how he goes well
then it's a [ __ ] double line and how
he goes we don't do double wide you
wasted my [ __ ] time and then he
slammed the phone down and then he just
woke up and he's stuck going like this
with his hands he would just start you
know screaming and then he just walked
out of the office he because nobody has
any [ __ ] money and the whole everyone
was making money every
but whose funny people thought it was
funny was a good breakup of the day hmm
I remember I was at his house Jim blow
with him once and he goes I want to move
to Santa Domingo because they treat you
like a [ __ ] person I mean I don't
even know I just started laughing I was
like I don't even know what that means
but he was so bad at sales like he
didn't know any of the programs he
didn't know how to sell anybody on
anything and he would just try to
refinance people that lived in like
boats
he didn't care but I just started
thinking about him because I'm like the
facts never like the facts were so
unimportant to him like if you sat down
with him and you showed him like you
like listen buddy you've closed no loans
you've made no money he would spit in
your face I keep it like you know [ __ ]
he's like you think here's you think I
you think I'm making money here because
I was waiting to make money here it'd be
[ __ ] dead are you [ __ ] nuts you
can't nobody can make any money here
people the bosses like everyone is
making money everybody is making money
but he was just completely unhinged I
mean he didn't I've told the story
before but he did one of the craziest
things ever where he sat down at a
closing and he said the APR which is the
annualized percentage rate which is the
cost of what the mortgage cost you with
all the financing included into it he
literally look somebody straight in the
face and went they go why is the APR
rate higher than the contract rate the
note rate whatever and the answer is
well it's because it includes the cost
of financing so but instead of saying
that he said well that honey that's the
average person rate and you're better
than average so we gave you a lower one
and the closing attorney to call my
company goes week this guy did go this
guy is out of control
we can't even but the amount of times
that he would try to refinance a modular
home and then find out it's a double
wide because this is a guy that talked
big steak houses money comic and then he
was just trying to refinance homes that
people could get in and drive away and
then he would fight because to be a
modular home like you'd hear
phonies like yeah we do modulars do you
have the modular certification I think
somebody said something like well
hearing mobile homes better says he goes
will you shut up god I'm on the phone
with a client and he'd be like do you
have the modular paper can you please
bring me the modular I mean but it got
me thinking what we were talking about
earlier in the shows like there are
people that you'll meet in life where
the statistics the facts the real story
what's actually happening have no
interest it's like so they feel about
reality the way I feel about astrology I
know like a little about it and I don't
really care I see it occasionally in a
magazine briefly and I'm like oh that's
interesting
that's the way a lot of people feel
about reality that's the way Howie Howie
there was this guy Mike just kind of
Mike they used to work there and he was
like the older guy you got to realize
all of this this is a company started by
24 year old who used to sell drugs and
his lawyer was like we can't get you off
as you get popped again you got to sell
something else who he discovered
mortgages and he started make it like 90
grand a month cuz every but all the guys
that got kicked out of stocks went into
mortgages and I was like a young kid and
I went in and I was just on the phone
getting applications handing them off
making a few bucks here and there
part-time College I hadn't gone full in
yet I hadn't quit college and bought the
house it did all that but I remember
going into this office and there was an
older guy who drove a Honda Civic this
guy Mike and Mike was the guy who owned
the company I don't want to say his name
I don't want to say everybody's name but
the guy who owned the company his uncle
was like the guy that was supposed to be
the office manager the HR guy Human
Resources and he was a respectable guy
that was lured out of some version of
corporate America but he drove a civic
so how he would be like how he would
just be like like Mike would try to talk
to Howie about how he's like behavior in
the office but how he didn't respect him
because he drove a Civic
you know and he just clearly was like
didn't have a lot of money and nobody
knew how how he had money but he had
some money so how he's just like I'm got
a guy in his Civic he goes because they
got a homeless guy telling me how to
behave in this office he goes I mean I
don't understand he goes how does this
office work you have you have you know
the vagrant telling me how to conduct
myself in the boardroom he used to call
the office the boardroom by the way I
mean it's like if anything could have
been less of a boardroom it was this we
gave the guy who delivered there was a
deli called sue John's where this Asian
guy would make sandwiches he answered go
ahead sue John and you got a high school
John and I go hi can I get cracked
pepper turkey ham lettuce tomato
mayonnaise cracked pepper on a hero
macaroni salad Nestle Quik talked about
a lunch they'll take you out of the game
soo-jung go yeah yeah yeah okay and then
he would send the Spanish guy that we
called Eddie who knew what his real name
was was Eddie
so how he swear to God hired Eddie to
start calling Spanish leads okay how he
was like the reason that I'm not making
money as I can't speak different
languages
everybody's like no the reasons you
don't even know what you're saying you
sound like a crazy person and the only
people that will talk to you our people
that have like modular I will say this
about Howie funnest person maybe top 3
funnest people I've ever spent any time
with ok I mean he walked into the
Christmas party coked out of his face it
was like a beautiful like catering hall
not beautiful but whatever Long Island
and he goes I he walks it uh he walked
it uh he walks in to eat looks he takes
a quick look around it goes oh good a
[ __ ] and then just kept walking just
keeps getting drunk on free booze
because so good a [ __ ] um but he
hired this Spanish guy three days later
the Spanish guy starts crying in the
office
we're like Eddie what's wrong Holly gets
him to quit his job delivering food at
sujod deli
we get to the quitter job he's like I'm
not working I have no money how would
not give me nothing man
he gave me nothing and likes Uncle
Michael how in Yukie cuz you can't do
this
we never hired this guy how is that
gonna have to run my decisions by you
Mike's like you absolutely do you a
hundred percent too
you know this guy is you have him in
here calling leads he's now crying he's
upset you got him to quit his job he has
no money as a daughter how he goes I
didn't tell him to have a daughter it's
a daughter but this is the type of
stunts that he would pull this guy was
balling this poor guy we went over to
we're like we're sorry man people are
giving him money how he's standing
outside smoking a cigarette were like
did your guy you hired his crying how
he's like well whatever works is he's
doing it on the phone trying to sell
leads we're like no he's having a
breakdown because you you're not paying
him you got him to put his job I was
like well smoking cigarettes well he's
do that a lot ago sociopath he's crazy I
mean the guy was bonkers put so much fun
that like it's hard to describe how much
fun he was and a guy like that you're
like oh he couldn't even do that much
damage to anyone because he could barely
sell anything right so like as much as
you'd want to blame someone like that
for the financial crisis he's maybe the
most innocent person in the building
because he didn't sell anything
he was just selling cocaine to people
that would have bought cocaine anyway in
that mortgage office two people died of
an overdose in the time that I worked
there till one of them was a friend of
mine I really liked he died and we all
went to his funeral
it was [ __ ] crazy and uh he died and
then a secretary also died and and the
guy who sold my friend the drugs worked
in the company so then he had to leave
and go somewhere it was kind of like
while it was wild time I don't know how
many of you I have
in that type of environment probably not
many but it was [ __ ] crazy dude and
we start you know I still remember that
having to go to the funeral having to go
into work and you know his parents being
there his sister you know going into his
desk Singh's desk was very very hard and
he was a great this guy was a great guy
who died it was like sad it was [ __ ]
dude wood ripped everybody up in the
office it tore everybody up and uh I'd
the guy that sold in the [ __ ] truck
like was in the office so it was like it
was a crazy time to to exist in this
space so that guy could like never go
back cuz people wanted to kill him this
guy's friends like we're gonna kill this
guy
you shouldn't have sold him that you
know and I mean of any situation that
I've ever worked in any situation that
I've ever worked in that first company
that I did mortgages in was the craziest
group of people forget comedy for a
second just let's talk about the real
world being out there the amount of
people that were assembled in that
office were some of the wildest people
and the craziest people there was a guy
in that office there were so many people
in that office but there was a guy in
that office and I mean I can't say names
but I wish I could because these
people's names are so perfect and you
immediately start to understand who they
are if I said their names but I can't
say their names but there was a guy in
the office who was an older guy he used
to wear like a button-down shirt with
like like it was like down to here down
to here and just like his chest hair out
and it was just like no everybody was
like what the [ __ ] is this guy doing and
he was just he was like this Italian guy
his name was Jim something and you know
think of an Italian food dish that you
like chicken cacciatore crumb Jim
cacciatore same thing and he would call
people up and he didn't know anything so
like every two seconds on the phone he'd
have to hold on one second
and he put them on hold they go what's
the deal with this and they would go
just get their info call him back and
then he'd go back on and go
I think the 30-year loan is the best
loan for you to take well there's a few
reasons for that hold on why why are
they taking it why are they taking it so
like on the other end of the phone you
just were put on hold put on hold put on
hold put on hold
cuz he knew not like he didn't know
anything he didn't even know what a
mortgage was he had no idea what was
going on like any every two seconds he'd
have to stop and he'd have to ask
somebody and eventually people like
listen [ __ ] just just you know
generalize but I mean there was there
was a lot of wild people in that office
I will go through them one by one one
day on a podcast I tried to pitch a show
that was not that office but another
office that I worked in which was sadder
because it was 2009 in the market had
crashed
so it was sadder and therefore funnier
the 2009 office but the office that I
worked in in 2006 2005 2006 was the
height of insanity the height of crazy
the height of drugs the height of MA
it was probably I was the height of my
drug use it was when I would take a more
feel like somebody him a pill they'd be
like I'd be like what is this TB like
it's morphine I would take a morphine
pill and get into my Oldsmobile 88 which
barely worked like I would hit the brake
sometimes in the whole car would stop
and I was on morphine and I'm like a boy
like starting it again getting it going
and then I'd have to continue to drive
home but legitimately
you know and that's when the coke came
back heavy the coke came back super
viii and i would just i owed bonnie at
one time i owed people thousands of
dollars just in cocaine and I would just
sniff Alana cocaine and then I would
just call people on the phone back hey
how are you this is Tim Dylan with
Franklin first has everything going and
then I would you know try to pitch them
and everything and just do more cocaine
and more cocaine it was bad it got to a
point where I was just I forget where I
was living at that time I was living in
a windowless basement apartment in
Massapequa Long Island doing cocaine and
then I moved into another apartment in
Long Beach which I barely lived in I was
doing cocaine there it was this way and
then I finally bought that house but the
the the drug regimen was strong and it
was a lot of [ __ ] it was a lot of late
night to that guy how his house just
sitting there listening to him go crazy
sometimes his coke was better than other
if he was doing it with you was okay if
he was selling it to you is horrific and
and then we'd go out as a company we'd
get in his little limo his little shitty
old limo drive to the city and then we
go to these nightclubs and then like you
know these goons would party and we just
danced and drank it with checks and do
coke and then the boss of our company
just punched this guy once so that we
all got kicked out it was just like that
type of event or we go to this place
Mirage in Long Island and Mirage was
like this or it was this massive mega
Club right in the middle of Long Island
and it was like you know gold digger
just come out and all these crazy so
everybody would just dance and do blow
and drink and it was just a true
religion jeans and a lot of cocaine and
it was like you know you couldn't have
if you had gone in any of those clubs
you would go oh everyone in here
deserves a financial crisis like you
deserve it
there's not too many clubs you could
walk in where you wouldn't feel like
that by the way but there's something
about those Long Island people that are
so confident they're so self-assured
they know what's going on wha
just watch this is the way it's gonna
work do you have any facts watch there's
something about seeing those people have
a good time and really just drink and
get loose where you want that you want
like something horrible to happen you
like sit there and you look at these
people they're getting away with it all
their ignorance all their idiocy and
they're dancing around and you guy just
kind of want a crisis a financial crisis
to just kind of thin this herd at least
there'll be less of them at least
there'll be less people dancing in this
warehouse if we thin it out you know but
it was some of the credit I wonder where
those people are right now I don't and I
I don't wonder like I'll ever trust get
in touch with them
not that much I don't wonder that much
but I do wonder what happened to some of
them because some of those people
probably ended up in jail I heard that
guy ended up in jail how he I could be
wrong some of those people maybe ended
up you know doing too many drugs and
dying I heard a few other people from my
if you could do a tally of how many
people are still alive from that period
of my life or how many people you know
how many people from that office died it
would be high it would be very very you
look like you're gonna ask a question
we're not okay you had a face it would
be an uncomfortably high number of
people that died I went to two or three
funerals in that era of people one was a
car accident but you know that a lot of
that was brought on by one was the OD in
the office and then there was this other
one but it was just [ __ ] tough this
podcast is supported by wix.com there's
a better way to build websites for your
clients with wicks harness the latest
web technology and innovative design
tools publishing a click make edits fast
your clients will enjoy enterprise-grade
security an automatic web hosting ok use
industry-leading
SEO and powerful marketing tools to
drive traffic to other sites get started
on your next client website today go to
wix.com slash g th one where
dot-com /g th 1 scale your web business
I'm sitting on the toilet of the hotel
Hilton in Houston Texas I'm telling you
right now if you do not have a website
in this [ __ ] world you're over
curtains you're done okay so what you
need to do is set up a website with Wix
you can't afford anything else right now
and you don't need anything else they
are professional sites you can use them
to market yourself get yourself out
there many of you are [ __ ] gold
you're just gold but you haven't been
discovered you're sitting in a riverbed
somebody needs to you know pick you up
and then shake that little tin and then
go that's gold I'm just remembering a
scene from the movie White Fang but the
point is your goal some of you are
platinum some of you are like moon rocks
we don't even know how good you are but
if you get a website using Wix
whoo-hee her gonna be rockin and rollin
the only reason that many of you are not
as successful as you want is many of you
it's your brain but a lot of you and is
that you do not have a Wix website your
website looks like [ __ ] well you don't
have one or you're relying simply on
social media which does not make you
look professional every body has a
social media account people's dogs and
cats have you need to have a website
that makes you look like a business a
business as a website are you a business
or are you a [ __ ] fraud even frauds
have websites let me take that back are
you a business or are you nothing
because the only thing that doesn't have
a website is nothing wix.com GTH one
I'll say that again
Wix calm /g th one that's the way to do
it I have to now get ready I'm on the
road with Bert we've had a great [ __ ]
week go get a Wix site
start your journey to prosperity it's
very very tough to watch these stories
about people that are on opioids and
taking pills and it's very very tough I
mean it's like it's brutal it rips
families apart and you know just [ __ ]
dude it's an epidemic it's a disease you
know and then you have this family the
Sackler family that like owns oxycontin
you know trying to like bribe people to
get to say this not addictive
you know God love them it's brutal man
and I did a few of those pills I did
oxys a few times due to wasn't my thing
I ended up just scratching myself I like
to perk a doodle a vicodin but even that
wasn't my thing you know you just
scratch yourself you get a euphoria I
mean I did I loved percocet in the
morning percocet in the morning you get
in your car you take two percocet you
got two eggs over-medium bacon and
cheese salt pepper ketchup on a roll and
you get like a double latte from
Starbucks and you just drive to work
with that and then you fart you'll kill
yourself by the fart of all of those
things you'll literally just kill
yourself in the car
but I would drive to work and I would
smoke like seven cigarettes and the
perky high is great and then you're at
work and you started chewing and you're
like this is it sucks you know and you
always felt strung out that was never my
my [ __ ] jam but Allah I saw a lot you
know a kid that I went to school with
od'd and we ended up going to his
funeral that was a third funeral I want
to like there's a lot of people that
they do they're a drug counselors people
who spent years and drug counseling
counseling addicts and they go to
funerals every month because they know
that that so if you're out there if
you're listening to the show and you do
anything like that you know get help
because that's you cannot kick that
alone Gary Vee isn't gonna help you kick
it it's not getting a positive attitude
go to rehab like go to a program if you
can I know with insurance it's shitty
but I mean I know a lot of people that
die it's not something that people
recover from you know it's not like
falling out of ketosis can back into
guitar I had a biscuit oh that's not
this this is a major problem and when I
look at the height of my drug use the
height of it was was in I would say 2006
2007 when I was just a drug addict like
totally worthless completely incapable
of functioning without not only drugs
but the idea that there would be drugs
if I did this and that I'm like well
I'll get I'll be able to get high if I
if I do if I complete these tasks I'll
be able to get [ __ ] up and dude what I
think what kept me alive is that I
didn't mix drugs as kind of a [ __ ] when
I drank I drank when I did coke I did
coke people always thought that was so
weird when I did pills I did pills I
didn't drink and do pills I did not mix
drugs and I was a purist but nobody boat
I think that's what kept me alive I
think if there's anything that kept me
alive it was luck maybe some form of
genetics and [ __ ] the idea that I
just didn't really mix a lot of those
drugs because you see when these
soundcloud rappers and I am dating
littlez and when these soundcloud
rappers unfortunately a lot of them die
because they mix they take lean I don't
even know what lean it what is lean
coughs you're up there I mean a real
issue here the kids are really the drugs
kids are on today I mean it's crazy it's
literal pharmaceuticals literal they're
ordering them from Merck and Novartis I
mean these kids and they're all tiny
little kids and they're so [ __ ] high
they're so tiny and so high so small and
so [ __ ] up it's amazing when you see
somebody that small be like yeah yeah
yeah just completely how long have we
done here 48 okay we're about to we're
about to wrap this puppy get the [ __ ]
out of here I got a
on tour with Burton we got to start
doing some sketches we're gonna put
together some more that mortgage stuff I
don't know how the better I don't know
the best way to do that maybe it's
animated
maybe it's sketches but we need to take
that it's got to go somewhere I was
trying to pitch a show where a lot of
those stories would go in there and
unfortunately it's just not on anybody's
uh to-do list it's not on any network's
to-do list but dude the reason that I've
always liked those types of people and
the reason that I connect with them even
as a comedian still is because when you
start like any job that's creative or
maybe it's your own business in the
beginning nobody believes you everybody
thinks you full of [ __ ] so the facts
have to take a backseat to the idea and
the ideas and the delusion and that is
incredibly healthy you need that you
can't overdose on the delusion because
you end up 38 with four roommates in a
coffee house talking about you know you
know Russia and Trump and Mike pants and
you're tweeting at Bernie Sanders and
he's a Russian agent that's when you too
much solution no good but in the
beginning you need to be a little crazy
so I've always kind of I myself am a
little crazy to do what I do is a little
crazy to want to do what I do is a
little crazy and I think that I've
always kind of you know had a soft spot
for people that were a little out there
because they not only didn't make the
world less boring but without those
types of people without the tenacity of
crazy a lot of the greatest [ __ ] that we
have would never have been brought into
reality would have never been brought to
fruition because you know everybody
tells you all the time to just walk the
path that everybody walks and then if
you go outside of that path you know it
takes not only some guts but I think it
also takes you gotta be a little nuts I
meet people all the time and I'm like oh
you're not gonna succeed because you are
too sane
you're too normal you're too sane like
your eyes are all dotted your tees are
all crossed and that's a great life but
it's gonna prevent you from going to the
places that you need to go to get great
at what you're trying to do the risks
you have to take you're not gonna take
the people that you're gonna have to
become friendly with you're not gonna
become friends with probably because
you're gonna look at them if it will
what you're not gonna shake your life up
to the extent that it needs to be shaken
up together a really different result
from the one that you're getting right
now and so when I talk to people people
message me like they let you have any
advice on commonly people message me and
it's like obviously I always say don't
do it hahaha joke joke be crazy a little
bit like what would be the craziest
thing and I don't mean be crazy like
live in a tent I mean like if the
craziest thing for you would be to move
to New York or move to Los Angeles and
and totally change your life and and
change the relationship you have with a
lot of your friends and your family if
you if that feels [ __ ] bonkers if
that feels batshit crazy do it whatever
the thing is it feels batshit crazy do
it because if you don't do it you know
you might regret it you might not you
might regret it if you do it now here's
where I that wheat wears like because
that you're like well I thought you
herded garyvee here's the other part of
this this is what Gary leaves out if you
do it the chance it will pan out is so
small it's like a head of a pin head of
a pin lotto is much better chances play
lotto much better chances and the chance
that even if it does work out it won't
completely destroy you is zero so
that'll be there you go with that I mean
find something you love and let it kill
you that's what it is don't let it kill
you
no but I laying these Sunday morning in
yeah yeah no but it's all about so I
still look fondly I look at my time with
those people fondly even though they
were crazy and I don't know where they
are now and they were a lot of them were
the bad kind of crazy some of them were
the good kind of crazy but really it's
always a mix it's always a mix it's
never just the good kind or the bad kind
you always get a little bit of both and
that's what I take away from those
people sometimes facts can't matter
you just gotta [ __ ] go out there and
see what you can do and then sometimes
facts should matter she's got a land on
Earth eventually you got a land first
couple of years you can just kind of
like hey you have that feral
look about you you're just trying to
claw your way somewhere but eventually
you got to pay the piper
you got a land on earth and that's the
way it is and I don't know where those
people are right now I imagine that some
of them maybe you know these are the
types of people that would throw their
mothers down the stairs to inherit a
house I mean literally literally would
push their elderly mother down the
stairs and you'd hear I go cuckoo cuckoo
and they would go ma you know this is
the type of people they were but I still
look back at the times we had together
and some of the lunches and the dinners
and the late-night chats and I say you
know what they were very very very bad
people
maybe Who am I God but they were a lot
of fun and fun people go one of two
places to rehab or to jail
that's where fun people go truly fun
people not like uncle Terry's fun
remember when he dressed up like a shut
up that's not what I mean
I mean really fun people really fun like
100 miles an hour and their Porsche
Cayenne doing rails screaming smoking
BOTS laughing fun real fun not you
goofball [ __ ] you people it's uncle
Jerry he used to dress like Santa and
one time you wore a bikini will you shut
up the adults are talking about real fun
people have abandoned their families to
have fun that's how much fun they were
they left their wife and children to go
have fun
that's how much they were committed to
fun
and those people unfortunately the
window of time they can be fun sadly
very short but those people sitting in
them modular home in South Carolina
they're better off for having talked to
one of the Psychopaths maybe I don't
know probably not but it was a way it's
a way for them to pass the day No Deal
got done nobody took care how I mean
nothing happened it was just some waste
of time you know some very very when you
look back at what humor really is at the
end of the day humor is a way to waste
time in the best way possible it's
really that's what you do with it you're
wasting time but it's the best way to
waste time and now I have to go here get
on a plane and get on a bus so I can
continue to waste my life in the best
way that I know how tim de la comédie
calm for all live dates good luck